were you in the generation where you
where people were watching things on
mega
uploads yeah oh yeah yeah do you
remember do you remember the dance you
had to do with the 72 minutes
time limit so for anyone too young to
know yeah
for anyone too young to know there used
to be this site called mega upload right
where people would upload you know full
tv series and
four movies on it yeah now most movies
they're on time it's normally like at
least an hour and a half
right like 100 minutes yeah yeah like
like 100 like 100 minutes
so mega upload for free account had a
time limit
of 72 minutes and for every 72 minutes
you watch
you had to wait 72 minutes to watch the
to to watch it again right such a dick
move yet
amazing marketing choice oh my god it
was such a dick move
like i don't know why like was it
because it was the only site that was
available
it was one of the only file sites that
was like welcome
everything you want
yeah and i remember back in the day when
because this was when i was in
university
so i i think back back when mega upload
was popular i don't think
vpns were as popular right because vpn's
vpn would be like the easy answer to
this nowadays right
and i remember feeling like i was like
so [ __ ] five-head
where what i would do is our university
had like a private network that we would
connect to to upload like our files or
upload our projects and stuff like that
all right um and so what i would do is i
would watch the 72 minutes then i would
connect
to the to the uh to the university
internet and start uploading on there
was like the eduroam
huh eduroam something like that right
and then that worked great
until i did something stupid i started
blabbing in my mouth about it
so unfortunately i lived in a shared
house
so so this 72 minutes the 72 minute
limit
became like five minutes where everyone
in our house started watching mega
uploads
and you used like the same network and
used the same same ideas
and uh yeah that was and then i realized
it's just much better to live by
yourself and just not have to deal with
people
sharing your internet do you remember
having to remember trying to game online
on university internet
and how [ __ ] awful that was terrible
yeah
it says there's a memory i don't want to
think about yeah i have like flashbacks
of just the ping going from 10 to like
500.
who's the loading porn i mean it wasn't
even that bad for me because like
because of australian internet our
default ping was like 300.
so it was more like going from like
three hundred yeah like nine hundred
game in the show and they were like yeah
i've got great ping oh what is it off
300.
that's not no measurement is that a good
thing if you have below 250 you're like
damn this guy's paying for like the
premium internet
i don't know i i i feel that uh
university internet was just the most
temperamental thing ever yeah but it's
really cool because i remember
that uh because a lot of them use the
eduroam network i remember once i went
to germany and i walked past university
and i was like oh i connect to the
internet
i can't see that university's internet
right right they shared the same
uh id for like wi-fi or something or
something like that right but if i walk
past any university you get free wi-fi
when you're a university student wow if
it was using the same network
which most of them were i think in
europe it's really cool fun fact wow
life hack yeah life hack just i don't
know do something walk past these kids
just get a
free wife just get free wi-fi stop
complaining it's free